do
[Music]
salt affected soils include both cylin
and sodic soils
[Music]
saline soils contain an excessive amount
of soluble salts
the presence of soluble salt
makes it difficult for plants to absorb
water from the soil
sodic soils carry high amounts of
absorbed sodium ions that damage soil
structure
soils become hard and compact when dry
and sticky when wet
both sideline and sodium conditions
considerably reduce the agricultural
productivity
over
833 million hectares are salt affected
soils
the map currently covers 73 percent of
the global land area
what are the drivers of salt affected
soils
there are natural and human endoscine
and sodic soils
in arid semi-arid and coastal
environments cylinder and sodic soils
are naturally present
these soils are not degraded but typical
of these landscapes where halophetic
vegetation is present
the uni salt flat in bolivia is an
example of this type of landscape and
soil
all the cylinder soils surrounding the
lake are used to produce crops
particularly the quinoa reel which is a
very nutritious crop
these soils also produce natural
vegetation eaten by camellids
human-induced salinization and
sodification
the main drivers are unsustainable
agricultural practices
irrigation with poor quality water
removal of deep rooted vegetation
resulting on raised water table
water pumping at the coastal plains
overuse of fertilizers
[Music]
because of climate change soils at
coastal areas are facing seawater
intrusion
causing salinity and sodisity
what can we do
[Music]
conserve natural ecosystems
prone to salinity and sodicity
[Music]
manage soils and water sustainable
apply appropriate irrigation practices
and adapted crops
[Music]
manage salt-affected soils in harmony
with nature
[Music]
let's work together to halt soil
salinization and boost soil productivity